N64 Superman, crap.
Favorite game, best game? Favorite game?
By far, not there's not even.
I mean, I've got my top five
but the number one game ever made,
"Mario Kart: Double Dash."
Ooh
Okay, so yeah. Why
specifically Double Dash?
Yeah, cause that double dash mechanic
of having two characters inside the cart
where both of them can
have special weapons.
You can switch who the driver is.
So you can decide which
item you're throwing
at your opponents.
Unbelievable. Incredible for
its time, incredible for now.
But they just decided
to not do that anymore.
Let's go back to regular
Mario Kart because that's fun.
It is fun.
The latest Mario Kart.
Incredible. So much fun.
So fun
Where the hell is double dash?
Wait. So double dash was
basically what was it?
Was it for
What was it? What was it on?
It was on Game Cube.
It's on Game Cube.
It's the reason I have a Game Cube.
Still? Do you still have
it? Yeah. Yes, good.
The memory card, fully beat.
I don't know. I don't
think that there's for me
at least there's not another game
that's as replayable as that.
You can play friends,
I can play by myself and I am ecstatic.
Also the fact that you can play two player
two players on the same kart
Aah,
Wait what!
Game-changing.
Yes. So you help each other steer
and drive and shoot the weapons.
Whoa, that's insane.
The strategies, the strategies
Yes
I mean that's so cool.
It's like in Halo.
Someone can drive the warthog
and someone can shoot.
Yeah its absolute,
But Mario Kart, but in Mario Kart
But its cute
I'm not saying Master
Chief isn't cute by the way
Under the helmet? Wow, what a guy.
So in high school is when this game came
out and the girl that I dated,
we did two things constantly.
One of them was played Double Dutch
and so we're very good at, well,
The other one was yell at each other
and that's why we broke up.
Yes.
Let's play Superman.
Yeah, let's play Superman.
Yeah. Yes.
But she was the best woman in my wedding.
She was my best woman.
Wow. Oh my God
My double dutch for life
Oh my God